you know that feeling you get when you
have two mirrors facing each other and
it gives the illusion of there being an
infinite tunnel of rooms or if they're
at an angle with each other it makes you
feel like you're a part of a strange
kaleidoscopic world with many copies of
yourself all separated by angled pieces
of glass what many people may not
realize is that the idea underlying
these illusions can be surprisingly
helpful for solving serious problems in
math we've already seen two videos
describing the block collision puzzle
with its wonderfully surprising answer
big block comes in from the break lots
of cuts the total number of clacks looks
like pi and we want to know why
here we see one more perspective
explaining what's going on where if the
connection to PI wasn't surprising
enough we add one more unexpected
connection to optics but we're doing
more than just answering the same
question twice this alternate solution
gives a much richer understanding of the
whole setup and it makes it easier to
answer other questions and fun side note
it happens to be core to how I coded the
accurate simulations of these blocks
without requiring absurdly small time
steps in huge computation time the
solution from the last video involved a
coordinate plane where each point
encodes a pair of velocities here we'll
do something similar but the points of
our plane are going to encode the pair
of positions of both blocks again the
idea is that by representing the state
of a changing system with individual
points in some space problems and
dynamics turn into problems in geometry
which hopefully are more solvable
specifically let the x coordinate of a
2d plane represent the distance from the
wall to the left edge of the first block
what I'll call d1 and let the y
coordinate represent the distance from
the wall to the right edge of the second
block what we'll call d2 that way the
line y equals x shows us where the two
blocks clack into each other since this
happens whenever d1 is equal to d2
here's what it looks like for our
scenario to play out as the two
distances of our blocks change the
two-dimensional points of our
configuration space move around with
positions that always fully encode the
information of those two distances you
may notice that at the bottom there it's
bounded by a line where d2 is the same
as the small blocks width which if you
think about it is what it means for the
small block to hit the wall you may be
able to guess where we're going with
this
the way this point bounces between the
two bounding lines is a bit like a beam
of light bouncing between two mirrors
the analogy doesn't quite work though in
the lingo of optics the angle of
incidence doesn't equal the angle of
reflection just think of the first
collision a beam of light coming in from
the right would bounce off of a
45-degree angled mirror this x equals y
line in such a way that it ends up going
straight down which would mean that only
the second block is moving this does
happen in the simplest case where the
second block has the same mass as the
first and picks up all of its momentum
like a croquet ball but in the general
case for other mass ratios that first
block keeps much of its momentum so the
trajectory of our point in this
configuration space won't be pointed
straight down it'll be down into the
left a bit and even if it's not
immediately clear why this analogy with
light would actually be helpful and
trust me it will be helpful in many ways
run with me here and see if we can fix
this for the general case seeking
analogies in math is very often a good
idea as with the last video it's helpful
to rescale the coordinates in fact
motivated by precisely what we did then
you might think to rescale the
coordinates so that X is not equal to d1
but is equal to the square root of the
first mass m1 times d1 this has the
effect of stretching our space
horizontally so changes in our big
blocks position now results in larger
changes to the x coordinate itself and
likewise let's write the y coordinate as
square root of m2 times d2 even though
in this particular case the second mass
is 1 so it doesn't make a difference but
let's keep things symmetric
maybe this strikes he was making things
uglier and kind of a random thing to do
but as with last time when we include
square roots of masses like this
everything plays more nicely
with the laws of conserving energy and
momentum specifically the conservation
of energy will translate into the fact
that our little point in the space is
always moving at the same speed which in
our analogy you might think of meaning
there's a constant speed of light and
the conservation of momentum will
translate to the fact that as our point
bounces off of the mirrors of our set up
so to speak the angle of incidence
equals the angle of reflection doesn't
that seem bizarre in kind of a
delightful way that the laws of
kinematics should translate to laws of
optics like this to see why it's true
let's roll up our sleeves and work out
the actual math focus on the velocity
vector of our point in the diagram it
shows which direction it's moving and
how quickly now keep in mind this is not
a physical velocity like the velocities
of the moving blocks instead it's a more
abstract rate of change in the context
of this configuration space whose two
dimensions worth of possible directions
encode both velocities of the block
[Music]
the X component of this little vector is
the rate of change of X and likewise its
Y component is the rate of change of Y
but what is that rate of change for the
x coordinate well X is the square root
of m1 times d1 and the mass doesn't
change so it depends only on how d one
changes and what's the rate at which d1
changes well that's the velocity of the
big block let's go ahead and call that V
1 likewise the rate of change for y is
going to be the square root of m2 times
V 2 now notice what the magnitude of our
little configuration space changing
vector is using the Pythagorean theorem
it's the square root of the sum of each
of these component rates of change
squared which is square root of m1 times
v1 squared plus m2 times v2 squared this
inner expression should look awfully
familiar it's exactly twice the kinetic
energy of our system so the speed of our
point in the configuration space is some
function of the total energy and that
stays constant throughout the whole
process
remember a core over idealizing
assumption to this is that there's no
energy lost to friction or twinny of the
collisions all right so that's pretty
cool with these rescaled coordinates our
little point is always moving with a
constant speed and I know it's not
obvious why you would care but among
other things it's important for the next
step where the conservation of momentum
implies that these two bounding lines
act like mirrors
first let's understand this line D 1
equals D 2 a little bit better in our
new coordinates it's no longer that nice
45-degree x equals y line instead if we
do a little algebraic manipulation here
we can see that that line is x over
square root M 1 equals y over square
root M 2 rearranging a little bit more
we see that's a line with a slope of
square root M 2 over m 1 that's a nice
expression to tuck away in the back of
your mind after the blocks collide
meaning our point hits this line the way
to figure out how they move is to use
the conservation of momentum which says
that the value M 1 times v1 plus m2
times V 2 is the same both before and
after the collision now notice this
looks like a dot product between two
column vectors M 1 M 2 and V 1 V 2
rewriting it slightly for our rescaled
coordinates the same thing could be
written as a dot product between a
column vector with the square roots of
the masses and one with the rates of
change for x and y I know this probably
seems like a complicated way to talk
about a comparatively simple momentum
equation but there is a good reason for
shifting the language to one of dot
products in our new coordinates notice
that second vector is simply the rate of
change vector for the point in our
diagram that we've been looking at the
key now is that this square root of the
masses vector points in the same
direction as our collision line since
the rise over run is square root M 2
over square root of M 1 now if you're
unfamiliar with the dot product there is
another video on this channel describing
it but real quick let's go over what it
means geometrically the dot product of
two vectors equals the length of the
first one multiplied by the length of
the projection of the second one on to
that first where it's considered
negative if they point in opposite
directions you often see this written as
the product of the lengths of the two
vectors and the cosine of the angle
between them
so look back at this conservation of
momentum expression telling us that the
dot product between this square root of
the masses vector and our little change
vector has to be the same both before
and after the collision since we just
saw that this change vector has a
constant magnitude the only way for this
dot product to stay the same is if the
angle that it makes with the collision
line stays the same in other words again
using the lingo of optics the angle of
incidence and the angle of reflection
off this collision line must be equal
similarly when the small block bounces
off the wall our little vector gets
reflected about the X direction since
only its y-coordinate changes so our
configuration point is bouncing off that
horizontal line as if it was a mirror so
step back a moment and think about what
this means for our original question of
counting block collisions and trying to
understand why on earth PI would show up
we can translate it to a completely
different question if you shine a beam
of light at a pair of mirrors meeting
each other at some angle let's say theta
how many times would that light bounce
off of the mirrors as a function of that
angle remember the mass ratio of our
blocks completely determines this angle
theta in the analogy now I can hear some
of you complaining haven't we just
replaced one tricky setup with another
this might make for a cute analogy but
how is it progress it's true that
counting the number of light bounces is
hard but now we have a helpful trick
when the beam of light hits the mirror
instead of thinking of that beam as
reflected about the mirror think of the
beam as going straight
while the whole world gets flipped
through the mirror it's as if the beam
is passing through a piece of glass into
an illusory looking glass universe think
of actual mirrors here this wire on the
left will represent a laser beam coming
into the mirror and the one on the right
will represent its reflection the
illusion is that the beam goes straight
through the mirror as if passing through
a window separating us from another room
but notice crucially for this illusion
to work the angle of incidence has to
equal the angle of reflection otherwise
the flipped copy of the reflected beam
won't line up with the first part so all
of that work we did rescaling
coordinates and futzing through the
momentum equations was certainly
necessary but now we get to enjoy the
fruits of our labor watch how this helps
us elegantly solve the question of how
many mirror bounces there will be which
is also the question about how many
block collisions there will be every
time the beam hits a mirror don't think
of the beams getting reflected let it
continue straight while the world gets
reflected as this goes on the illusion
to the beam of light is that instead of
getting bounced around between two
angled mirrors many times it's passing
through a sequence of angled pieces of
glass all the same angle apart right now
I'm showing you all of the reflected
copies of the bouncing trajectory which
I think has a very striking Beauty to it
but for eclis review let's just focus on
the original bouncing beam and the
illusory straight one the question of
counting bounces turns into a question
of how many pieces of glass this
illusory beam crosses how many reflected
copies of the world does it pass into
well calling the angle between the
mirrors theta the answer here is however
many times you can add theta to itself
before you get more than half way around
a circle which is to say before you add
up to more than PI total radians written
as a formula the answer to this question
is the floor of pi divided by theta so
let's review
we started by drawing a configuration
space for our colliding blocks where the
x and the y coordinates represented the
two distances from the wall this kind of
looked like light bouncing between two
mirrors but to make the analogy work
properly we needed to rescale the
coordinates by the square roots of the
masses this made it so that the slope of
one of our lines was square root of m2
divided by square root of m1
so the angle between those bounding
lines will be the inverse tangent of
that slope to figure out how many
bounces there are between two mirrors
like this think of the illusion of the
beam going straight through a sequence
of looking-glass universes separated by
a semicircular fan of Windows the answer
then comes down to how many times the
value of this angle fits into 180
degrees which is PI radians from here to
understand why exactly the digits of pi
show up when the mass ratio is a power
of 100 it's exactly what we did in the
last video so I won't repeat myself here
and finally as we reflect now on how
absurd the initial appearance of pi
seemed and on the two solutions we've
now seen and on how unexpectedly helpful
it can be to represent the state of your
system with points in some space I leave
you with this quote from the computer
scientist Alan Kay a change in
perspective is worth ad IQ points
[Music]
you